what is herd immunity hi my name is
Howard Forman I'm a physician and a
professor at the Yale School of Public
Health and Yale School of Management I'd
like to talk about one method of
protecting people from covid-19 that's
been getting some attention herd
immunity
in simple terms herd immunity is
communal protection from a disease we
achieve it once a large proportion of a
population is immune to the disease and
presumably the ability to spread it
dramatically reducing the risk of spread
to others who are not immune you can
think of it as the percentage of a
population that must be immune to extend
immunity to others automatically the
safest way to do this is through
vaccination through vaccines we have
achieved herd immunity to many dangerous
diseases including measles whooping
cough and chickenpox herd immunity does
not mean no one can get the disease
isolated incidents can still occur but
it means a major outbreak is highly
unlikely before vaccines herd immunity
was achieved naturally but brutally
disease would spread unchecked survivors
would develop antibodies and Immunity
events actually enough people would be
immune to Halt spread until new
unimmunized members of society were
introduced generally via birth or
migration and then outbreaks could occur
again absent a vaccine herd immunity is
not a viable Public Health strategy in
the case of the virus that causes
covid-19 achieving herd immunity without
a vaccine would require allowing up to
70 percent of the U.S population to
become infected that's 231 million
people and since 0.4 percent of those
individuals at the lowest estimate would
die we would lose close to 1 million
Americans and leave countless others
with long-standing health problems this
violates a central tenet of biomedical
ethics first Do no harm to achieve herd
immunity to covid-19 through vaccination
a substantial percent of the population
must be vaccinated perhaps as high as 70
percent of those eligible in the
meantime we can prevent unnecessary loss
of life through patients and by
employing various strategies to manage
covid-19 spread including widespread
rapid testing and the isolation of those
found to be infected mask wearing
hygienic measures and social distancing
foreign